da sind wir herzlich willkommen zum
Presseclub und wir haben gerade die
aktuellen Nachrichten gesehen und gehört
und verfolgt was aktuell in Israel und
dem gazaastreifen passiert das ist etwas
was wir jetzt seit Tagen tun die
Auswirkungen beobachten dieses
furchtbaren terrorangriffs durch die
Hamas auf Israel was dort Kindern Frauen
alten Menschen angetan wurde das
übersteigt zum Teil wirklich unsere
Vorstellungskraft inzwischen gibt es
tausende to in Israel aber auch im
Gazastreifen und dort sind wiederum
inzwischen 100ta000ende Menschen auf der
Flucht in den Süden des Gazastreifens
wir haben es gerade schon gehört die
Bodenoffensive der Israelis ist erst
einmal vermutlich verschoben worden
unklar ist wie die Situation sich
überhaupt weiterentwickeln wird und
welche Akteure mitmischen werden unser
Thema heute im Presseclub Israel im
Krieg droht ein Flächenbrand im Nahen
Osten und ich freue mich auf meine
gästerunde und sage herzlich willkommen
Alexandra Schmidt stellvertretende
Chefredakteurin der Süddeutschen Zeitung
hat als Korrespondentin aus Israel und
auch aus den palästinensischen Gebieten
berichtet hasnin kim ist bei uns
herzlich Willkommen freier Journalist
und Autor Daniel Dillen Böhmer ist da in
unserer Runde eine aostexperte der Welt
und auch in unserer Runde Susanne glass
herzlich willkommen Leiterin des
Ressorts Ausland und politischer
Hintergrund beim Bayerischen Rundfunk
auch Korrespondentin gewesen langjährig
für die ARD in Tel Aviv und sie wissen
das wie immer streamen wir unsere
Sendung in den sozialen Netzwerken dort
können sie sich sehr gerne beteiligen
ihre Meinung
Ihre Fragen dort Teilen machen sie da
gerne mit Frau glass wir haben es jetzt
gerade gehört in den Nachrichten die
Bodenoffensive verschoben so heißt es
jetzt laut Medienberichten das heißt
aber sie kommt auf jeden Fall das wissen
wir ja nicht ganz genau ich denke was
wir auf jeden Fall wissen ist dass die
israelische Regierung einen Schlag gegen
die Hamas jetzt vornehmen muss das
erwarte das Land
aber im Moment
nach unseren Informationen könnte es
auch sein dass erst noch weiter gebombt
wird und dass man dann selektiv in den
Gazastreifen geht mit Bodentruppen aber
möglicherweise nicht diese ganz große
Offensive kommt aber Genaues wissen wir
ja nicht und das gehört ja auch zur
psychologischen Kriegsführung Frau F
Schmidt wir haben es ja auch gehört in
letzten Tagen der Aufruf der
israelischen Armee kam am Freitag dass
die Zivilbevölkerung sich in den Süden
des gaserre begeben soll gibt es
überhaupt eine Chance dass die
Zivilbevölkerung sich im Gasastreifen in
Sicherheit bringen kann dieser Aufruf
wurde heute noch mal bekräftigt es gab
ein TV Interview des israelischen
armeesprechers und es gab noch mal eine
offizielle verlaubbarung man möge sich
doch bis zum frühen Nachmittag in
Richtung süben begeben wenn man mal im
gaserstreifen war dann weiß man das es
schwierig es ist ein extrem dicht
besiedeltes Gebiet etwa äh die Fläche
von München da Leben 2,2 Millionen
Menschen und
das sind ganz dicht Häuser an Häuser
stehen da es sind Ruinen und es ist auch
wenig freie Fläche das heißt es gibt
schon viele bombenschäen wo sollen die
Menschen hin viele haben in den
vergangenen Tagen Schutz bei
un-einrichtungen gesucht es gibt 92
Schulen die die unr das Hilfswerk für
die Palästinenser dort betreibt da gab's
über 200 20.000 Menschen die Zuflucht
gesucht haben in der Annahme dass dort
nicht bombardiert wird aber es ist sehr
schwierig eben tatsächlich auch sich von
vom Norden in Richtung Süden zu bewegen
sind 40 km und was man auch hört aus dem
gaserstreifen dass die her Mass
Straßensperren errichtet das heißt es
auch schwierig macht für Menschen die
sich überhaupt auf den Weg machen dass
sie von Norden in Richtung Süden
gelangen können Herr Kim das alles was
was wir gerade erleben passiert vor dem
Hintergrund dessen was am Samstag
passiert ist vor gut einer Woche in
Israel m ich habe es gerade schon
angedeutet was dort den Menschen angetan
wurde ist wirklich unmenschlich woher
kommt diese
Steigerung also wenn ich das so richtig
einschätze hat die Hamas das ja schon
seit langem geplant immer wieder
angekündigt man wolle in Israel
eindringen man wolle
nutzen schlubflöcher im Zaun und wolle
so etwas anrichten insofern würde ich
das gar nicht als Steigerung bezeichnen
sondern es ist das erfüllt worden was
die Hamas immer permanent angedroht hat
und aber auch in dieser Unmenschlichkeit
in diesen Bildern die dazu gemacht
wurden na ja also man nutzt jetzt die
Hamas nutzt die Möglichkeiten die
medienmöglichkeiten die sie hat die hat
das das ist ja bewusst dass das gefilmt
wird dass das gestreut wird genauso wie
es bewusst ist dass die Hamas nicht nur
Straßensperren wie Frau föder Schmidt
gerade sagte errichtet sondern die Hamas
hat hat ausdrücklich aufgerufen den
Appellen der Israelis an die Zivilisten
im Gazastreifen ihre Häuser im Norden zu
verlassen nicht nachkommen soll sondern
sollen dort bleiben das heißt die Hamas
will dass es zivile Opfer gibt sie lebt
davon das ist eine Art von von ja
Kriegsführung sie profitiert davon weil
sie dann sagen kann schaut wie böse die
Israelis sind sie profitiert von den
zivilen Opfern und das ist Teil der der
der Strategie sie haben es gerade
angesprochen inzwischen WIS wir
eigentlich dass dieser Angriff wohl
lange geplant war Herr bümer wir haben
auch eine Frage dazu die ich gleich mal
mit reinnehmen möchte von unseren
Zuschauern wie kann es sein dass die
Geheimdienste dieser Welt nichts über
den Angriff der Hamas wussten wir wissen
es ist einer der besten Geheimdienste
der Welt in Israel es gibt die
grenzzaunsicherung die super modern ist
und am Ende geht's dann da ja mit
Motorrädern und Gleitschirmen rüber wie
kann das sein wir sind zwar in aktuellen
Situation aber es ist etwas was
natürlich jetzt wirklich schon gefragt
wird ja und das ist auch etwas was auch
Geheimdienstleute in aller Welt gerade
heftig diskutieren weil eigentlich
gewissermaßen die geheimdienstliche
Fachwelt die Israelis wahnsinnig
bewundert hat für das was sie können und
Sie können es auch tatsächlich ich
glaube es gibt da zwei Ebenen von
geheimdienstlicher Überwachung wo etwas
klappen muss um so etwas zu verhindern
das eine ist die technische das ist die
Überwachung z.B mit Drohnen aus der Luft
das ist die Überwachung der
Kommunikation die sogenannte Signal
intelligence die scheint sehr sehr gut
geklappt zu haben bei den Israelis das
Problem ist auf der menschlichen Ebene
bei den menschlichen Quellen bei den
Leuten die sagen können ob da wirklich
etwas passiert bei denen scheint es ein
Problem gegeben zu haben da scheint die
Panne passiert zu sein und das ist
deshalb nötig weil zumindest sagen einem
Leute die das Beobachten es sieht
eigentlich permanent so aus als wenn die
Hamas gerade genau einen solchen Angriff
plant weil die Hamas pausenlos Übungen
durchführt pausenlos Übungen durchführt
die auf Durchbrüche ausgerichtet sind
und zu wissen welche dieser Übung ist in
Wahrheit der Ernstfall dafür braucht man
Quellen dort unten und die haben in
diesem Fall nicht so funktioniert aber
genau aber ehrlich gesagt wenn man mit
Agenten drüber spricht auch westlichen
Agenten die sagen ja sowas kann leider
einfach immer passieren das bedeutet
nicht dass die Israelis am Ende doch
doof sind das ist einfach die Art von
Panne die immer sein kann frauass was
macht das mit dem Sicherheits Gefühl der
Menschen es ist ja schon so dass man
sich ja relativ sicher gefühlt hat
bisher in Israel wenn ich vielleicht
eins noch hinzufügen darf bei der Hamas
fand ich ja auch sehr spannend
offensichtlich haben sie mit
handgeschriebenen Zettelchen gearbeitet
und dadurch die cyper naation Israel
auch etwas ausgetrixst ja also ganz
analog unterwegs gewesen genau analog
unterwegs gewesen aber
Sicherheitsgefühl ich glaube das ist
eine ganz ganz große zesur was da jetzt
passiert ist und wenn man in einen
Schritt zurückgeht ist Israel ist nach
der Shoa errichtet worden um Jüdinnen
und Juden in der Welt einen sicheren
Hafen eine sichere Heimat zu bieten und
dieses Sicherheitsgefühl das war da wenn
auch labil ich habe ja selber lange
Jahre in Israel gelebt und habe einige
Kriege und Raketenangriffe miterlebt
aber man hatte immer das Gefühl der
eendom der schützt und schon die Armee
die Geheimdienste haben das im Griff und
jetzt ist diese Nation unter Schock man
muss die Zahlen ja auch mal hochrechnen
wenn wir sagen 1300
nehmen stellen wir uns vor wir hätten
hier diese Anzahl an Toten in
Deutschland was das mit was das mit
einem mit einem Land macht und deshalb
denke ich ist die Regierung jetzt auch
in einer Situation wo sie einen Schlag
vorbereiten muss der diesen Schock der
Menschen in ja in Rechnung hat aber wenn
ich noch eins sagen darf im Gasastreifen
das habe ich jetzt heute morgen gesehen
haben wir mittlerweile 2300 tote das
sind mehr als im zwei Monate andauernden
Krieg 2014 jetzt schon nach einer Woche
kann man auch nur erahnen wie sich das
dort weiterentwickeln wird jetzt kommt
möglicherweise diese Bodenoffensive wenn
wir das jetzt gerade schon gehört haben
Frau ferschmidt die braucht ja
eigentlich eine neue Dimension also dass
wir kennen dass es Luftschläge gibt auf
den gaserstreifen wir kennen auch dass
hamastunnel zerstört werden wird das
eine neue Dimension jetzt einfach haben
müssen sonst kann man das Gefühl ja gar
nicht mehr herstellen ja weil
die greudeltaten so schlimm waren und
wieso glass gesagt hat die haben sich
eingebrannt jetzt in das Gedächtnis der
Nation das war eine zesur und stellt
auch vieles von dem was bis an Kriegen
geführt wird in den Schatten diese
Brutalität vor ein paar Tagen wurden
weitere Bilder veröffentlicht vor allem
von zwei kiboim in Grenznähe ich habe
die Bilder
gesehen das kann man nicht beschreiben
was dort passiert ist und der Dr die
Erwartungshaltung ist sehr groß und
Israel hat ja jetzt auch eine
Notstandsregierung gebildet also alles
was an Spaltung der Gesellschaft auch
durch die Proteste wegen der
Justizreform da war das ist jetzt alles
hinter angestellt auch die Fehleranalyse
also ich glaube schon das auch technisch
wenn man sieht wie einfach die die
Grenze überwinden konnte also das sind
schon auch technische Fehler passiert
aber all das wird jetzt hinter
angestellt man muss jetzt en tatsächlich
mit der noch schwierigeren Situation
umzugehen weil man ja auch annimmt dass
zumindest ein Teil der 150 bis 200
Geisel die Zahl wurde gestern erhöht die
befinden sich in den Händen der Mast das
heißt die sind im gaserstreffen und das
muss man mit bedenken wenn man jetzt das
vorgehben plant man hat am Freitagabend
schon einzelne trups ausgeschickt war
schon auch ja mit kleineren ein en im
gaserstreifen drinnen um die Lage zu
sondieren hat dort offenbar auch tote
Geiseln gefunden also es wird alles viel
schwieriger und vor allem die her Mass
hat ein Tunnelsystem ein ausgeglügeltes
und es erklärt auch warum auch heute
Vormittag noch immer Raketen fliegen
also die schießen einfach ihre Raketen
ab ziehen sich wieder zurück in die
Tunnel aber sie sagen es gerade mit den
Tunneln das heißt da sind auch die
Bombardierungen nicht wirklich effektiv
unter
anführungs im Gazastreifen Aussehen Herr
bümer ja der wird wie die Israelis sagen
in der Gaza U-Bahn stattfinden der wird
zum großen Teil unter der Erde
stattfinden und das ist ein Szenario
dass die israelischen Streitkräfte auch
schon seit Jahren üben also die sind
darauf vorbereitet und ich glaube schon
dass es eine Bodenoffensive geben wird
ich halte es eigentlich von ausweichlich
und ich glaube das liegt nicht nur Frau
Fal Schmidt gewissermaßen in der
Psychologie der Eskalation dass die
Israelis jetzt einen harten Gegenschlag
erwarten sondern es liegt auch daran
dass einfach das strategische Konzept
des Umgangs mit Hamas von israelischer
Seite her gescheitert ist das was wir in
den letzten Jahren gesehen haben dass
die Hamas immer mal Raketen schießt und
dann kommt Israel mit einer mit einer
luftkriegsführung haut drauf und
reduziert die Bedrohung und dann ist für
eine Weile wieder Ruhe das ist jetzt
gescheitert was wir aus Israel hören ist
dass der Verteidigungsminister jof
Galland sagt wir wollen Hamas
ausradieren das sind sehr sehr harte
Worte und ich bin auch nicht sicher dass
das Israel politisch nutzt aber sicher
ist dass Israel jetzt militärisch eine
Situation herstellen muss wo so etwas
nicht mehr passieren kann wo diese
schwelende Bedrohung der Hamas wie sie
in Gazastreifen bisher geherrscht hat
nicht mehr existiert und das Problem ist
das zu erreichen wird ganz ganz schwer
weil die Hamas ist nicht nur im
gerstreif das ist auch eine Situation wo
natürlich diese Frage nach der
Verhältnismäßigkeit kommen wird Herr
Kassim die Nato hat schon gesagt okay
ihr habt das Recht euch zu verteidigen
aber bitte Verhältnismäßigkeit
Völkerrecht beachten das ist doch
eigentlich nicht möglich oder na ja
zunächst einmal grundsätzlich gilt
natürlich immer das Völkerrecht
einzuhalten aber das ist schon ein Stück
weit wohlfall denn wenn man sich
fragt und die Opfer sich anschaut und
die taten sich anschaut die manche sagen
unbeschreiblich sind ich finde nicht
dass sie unbeschreiblich sind sie sind
wahnsinnig brutal und eigentlich müsste
man das immer wieder beschreiben was da
passiert ist mit geköpften Säuglingen
und so weiter und so fort dann frage ich
mich was genau ist da verhältnismäßig
was soll denn da verhältnismäßig sein zu
dem was dort angerichtet worden ist an
Terror und deswegen verstehe ich schon
die israelische Regierung die sagt wir
sind wie danel den Böhmer sagt
gescheitert mit dem was wir bisher
gemacht haben wir müssen jetzt mit aller
Härte Vorgehen militärisch was natürlich
dazu führen wird dass gerade weil der
Gazastreifen so eng besiedelt ist
es wahnsinnig viele zivile trte geben
wird was die Hamas aber auch will das
nützt i ja auch so und also es wird es
wird ein ein ganz ganz schlimmes
Szenario sein es wird alles ganz
furchtbar sein aber was ist die
Alternative das Mus eine
Zivilbevölkerung die dort natürlich auch
lebt und
sie in einer sehr schwierigen Situation
ist fr sie haben auch Kontakte nach wie
vor in die Region und erfahren natürlich
auch wie die Menschen schon ohne die
Bodenoffensive gerade im im
gaserstreifen leiden darf ich mal
persönlich etwas sagen als ich gestern
hier angereist bin aus München habe ich
mich in München noch mit einer Freundin
getroffen einer Jüdin aus Israel die hat
drei Kinder ist jetzt ausgereist und
habe mit ihr gemeinsam geweint weil wir
auch Bekannte haben die unter diesen
Opfern sind weil niemand weiß wie es
weitergeht und weil diese Bilder eben
genauso schrecklich sind wie sie sie
beschreiben nie da gewesen und als ich
dann im Zug saß nach Köln hat mich im
Zug ähm ein guter Bekannter erreicht aus
Gaza den ich vergeblich versucht habe
lange anzu rufen das ist äh ein Oberarzt
der leitet die Neurochirurgie in einem
Krankenhaus in Gasa hat lange Zeit in
Deutschland gearbeitet ist jetzt
freiwillig vor einiger Zeit nach Gaza
und operiert dort äh ständig kleine
Kinder die zum Teil die ganze Familie
verloren haben er hat erzählt eine
neunjährige
hat beim letzten Luftschlag die ganze
Familie verloren er konnte ihr Leben
retten das war ein hochemotionales
Gespräch dass ich mit diesem Mann
geführt habe und in zwischen diesen
Polen bewegen wir uns glaube ich im
Moment alle
ähm und was mir aufgefallen ist bei
meinen letzten Besuchen ich war ja
wirklich sehr oft in Gaza die Menschen
haben sich von der Hamas los gesagt es
gibt eine große Anzahl in der
Bevölkerung in Gaza die wollte mit der
Hamas nichts mehr zu tun haben die hatte
die genauso gehasst
wie wie viele auf israelischer Seite ähm
und jetzt ist die Situation eben so dass
sie für die Verbrechen dieser
Terroristen äh in mit Leidenschaft
gezogen werden in
Mitverantwortung ich habe auch tagelang
jetzt versucht palästinensische bekannte
zu erreichen mir ist es so wie Susanne
gegangen und ich habe dann am Donnerstag
einen Bekannten getroffen ist auch
nachzulesen im Buch 2 der Süddeutschen
Zeitung und ein Vater mit fünf Kindern
das jüngste ein Jahre der einem sagt ich
weiß nicht wie ich meine Kinder die
nächsten Tage ernähren soll wir wissen
nicht mehr wo wir Wasser herkriegen wo
wir Nahrung herkriegen ich bin jetzt zum
Nachbarn gegangen es ist mir gelungen
für eine halbe Stunde das Handy
anzustecken wir haben keine Batterie
mehr das war jetzt unser letzter Strom
weil die Generatoren auch nicht mehr
laufen weil der Treibstoff aus ist das
ist die Situation vor Ort das ist kein
hamasanhänger und wie Susanne glass sagt
die Heras hat nicht geschafft seit 2007
die regieren unter Anführungszeichen da
im gaserstreifen die Versorgung der
Menschen sicherzustellen und 1,2
Millionen Menschen sind war oder Ware
muss man jetzt sagen vor dieser
Situation jetzt schon auf
Nahrungsmittelhilfe durch die UN
angewiesen das sind auch die
Hilfslieferung alles blockiert und auch
Ägypten hat zugemacht GI
Frage Leute raus und auch keine
Hilfsmittel rein darf ich die Frage
direkt mit reinnehmen wie kann es sein
dass Ägypten die Grenzen dicht macht und
keine Palästinenser im Land haben will
gebe ich gerne weiter Verhandlung gibt
auch die Frau berbock hat versucht da
jetzt bei ihren Gesprächen Kairo eben
das Thema anzusprechen ja da sind
tatsächlich im Moment die Ägypter die
diese Grenze dich halten auch übrigens
gegenüber den Amerikanern die ihre
eigenen Doppelstaatler da rausholen
wollen stundenweise das Öffnen genau
richtig und da müssen wir sehen einmal
Ägypten hat Angst vor der Flut der
Menschen die da kommen könnte wir reden
ja von von Mem einer Millionenzahl und
Ägypten hat glaube ich auch Angst vor
der Sicherheitslage die dann entstehen
könnte Ägypten hat jahrelang gekämpft um
diesen Teil des Landes die Sinai
Halbinsel frei zuukriegen von alada und
vom islamischen Staat die da jahrelang
ihr Unwesen treiben konnten weil dieses
Sina Gebirge wirklich ein perfektes
Schlupfloch für Terroristen ist wenn ich
noch ein Punkt hinzufügen darf zum Thema
Verhältnismäßigkeit und
Kriegsvölkerrecht das Kriegsvölkerrecht
sagt nicht es darf keine zivilen Toten
geben dasvölkerrecht erkennt die
Realität an dass es in Kriegen zivile
Tote gibt das Kriegsvölkerrecht schreib
vor dass beide Parteien größtmögliche
Anstrengung unternehmen müssen dass es
möglichst wenige zivile Tote gibt und
ich glaube das kann man bei Israel im
Moment sagen das kann man bei der Hamas
sicherlich nicht sagen die Hamas wie hin
K richtig sagt will diese zivilen Toten
Israelis sagen es sollen alle in den
Süden gehen und was ich ehrlich gesagt
im Moment wohlfeil finde ist die Haltung
der Vereinten Nationen denn der
Kommentar der Vereinten Nationen ist
erstens oh Gott das gibt doch Chaos wenn
jetzt alle in den Süd gehen ja richtig
Krieg ist auch Chaos und zweitens der
Lösungsvorschlag der Vereinten Nationen
ist doch einfach eine Waffenruhe zu
behalten ja das und das ist leider nicht
die Situation der wir sind das ist nicht
die Situation die die Hamas kreiert hat
genau und wenn ich ein Punkt noch
anmerken darf weil wir hier sprechen
über diese furchtbare Situation im
Gazastreifen hungernde Menschen Leute
die nicht wissen wie sie ihre Familie
ernähren sollen verletzte und so weiter
ich finde man muss dann schon und wir
reden über geschlossene Grenzen und
Blockade ich finde man muss schon ein
mal kurz in einem klaren Satz sagen für
diese Situation ist einzig und allein
die Hamas verantwortlich nachdem was sie
da veranstaltet hat das ist nicht die
Schuld von Ägypten das ist nicht die
Schuld Israels das muss man fin ich auch
aber vielleicht
die Schuld der Hamas aber es gibt
vielleicht auch noch andere Akteure die
Interesse daran hatten wie sich das
Ganze dort entwickelt den den Schritt
würde ich gerne mal mit Ihnen gehen und
das mal ein bisschen öffnen dass wir
nicht nur Israel und die Hamas sehen
oder sollten wir die nur sehen Frau Glas
haben sie die Befürchtung d ich wollte
auch noch eins
hinzufügen es ist absolut sie vollkommen
Recht jetzt die Schuld der Hamas was
passiert ist aber der Gasastreifen war
ja nicht nur von Israel abgeriegelt die
Ägypten hat ih mit abgeriegelt also ich
sage immer die die Not der Bevölkerung
klar durch das Regime der Hamas aber
Abriegelung war von Israel und von
ägyptischer Seite und im Gazastreifen
ist nicht nur die Hamas da ist auch der
islamische dihad ich habe es immer mal
wieder erlebt wir waren auch gemeinsam
da da waren dann
Checkpoints
der Hamas und ein Checkpoint des
Islamischen Jihad eben im letzten
schamützel
2021 im Mai da hat der islamische dihad
vor allem Raketen nach Israel
geschossen und die Hamas hat sich
zurückgehalten wohl damals schon im
wissen wir wollen so tun als wären wir
eine seriöse Partei hat aber
offensichtlich was wir jetzt wissen ja
schon diesen großen Schlag
vorbereitet also deshalb denke ich mir
auch was passiert denn eigentlich wenn
man die Hamas im Gazastreifen
vernichtend schlägt was passiert mit
Islamischen Jihad wer übernimmt da das
Kommando wie sehen da die Pläne für die
Zukunft aus will Israel da ganz rein
gibt es keine also irgendwelche
Geheimdienst werden sich ja wohl
Gedanken gemacht haben aber in der
Vergangenheit wollte man das ja ganz
genau vermeiden weil es keine Konzepte
gab und ich glaube auch dass die
Tatsache dass es keine Konzepte gab dass
ich in Israel immer gehört habe wie
Konflikt mit den Palästinensern wir
werden das schon irgendwie so unter der
Decke halten wir orientieren uns jetzt
Richtung arabische Welt wir schließen da
Abkommen mit anderen arabischen Ländern
das hat auch zu dieser Situation geführt
dass dieser Konflikt jetzt in dieser
Brutalität eskaliert ist und wird er
weiter eskaliert der Flächenbrand er ist
eskaliert also wenn man guckt was heute
vormittags los war diesespol hat sich
dazu bekannt es gab schon drei kleinere
Angriffswellen der Schiiten Miliz aus
dem Libanon was auch darauf hindeutet
dass tatsächlich Iran dahinter steckt es
gab auch aus Syrien in den vergangenen
Tagen einzelne Raketen die Richtung
Israel abgeschossen worden sind das
heißt da droh ein zwei oder sogar drei
frankenkrieg und all das ist
or Sicherheit von von
Iran weil die hamass logistisch kann wir
kaum vorstellen alleine durchführen
hätte können und wie gesagt der
iranische Außenminister war ja auch in
den vergangenen Tagen jetzt unterwegs in
der Region da wird gezündelt und dass
die hisbulah so mit diesen einzelnen
Schlägen jetzt schon mitmischt ist
natürlich auch ein Zeichen und
tatsächlich gab's heute auch auf
israelischer Seite einen Toten im durch
einen Angriff der aus dem Libanon kommt
her bitte ja ich glaube tatsächlich dass
es noch mehr als drei frunden sein
werden weil sie haben völlig recht
zumindest das die bedrohungskulisse mit
der wir es jetzt zu tun haben die hat
der Iran bewusst aufgebaut indem er
überall in der Region Milizen gefördert
hat von denen viele auch Israel
angreifen können wenn ich es kurz
aufzählen darf wir haben also wenn man
es als Uhr als Zifferblatt nimmt mit
Jerusalem in der Mitte dann haben wir
auf 12 Uhr die libanesischebolla die vom
Iran geführt wird dann haben wir auf 1
Uhr
in Syrien auch weitere hisbolla
Einheiten aber auch Einheiten der
iranischen revolutionsgarten dann haben
wir so ca auf 2 3 Uhr haben wir den Irak
wo es Irak von iranischen von Iran
ausgerüstete Milizen gibt deren Raketen
ebenfalls Israel treffen können dann
haben wir ca auf 5 Uhr die hui Milizen
im Jemen das ist zwar 2000 km entfernt
von Israel aber haben auch eine Karte
die wir uns
mal kann man sich das alles
bisschen haben die können auch Israel
angreifen und das ist das Problem in
diesem Konflikt dass die Hamas eben
nicht mehr nur eine palästinensische
Organisation ist ist auch ein Instrument
iranischer Strategie in der Region aber
was bedeutet das welche Unterstützer hat
Israel in der
Region welche Staaten also wir haben
jetzt erlebt Saudiarabien hat z.B
anierungsgespräch jetzt erstmal
gestopptesagt solange es diese Angriffe
gibt wir ziehen uns wieder zurück wer
wer bleibt na ja ich glaube nicht dass
das dieser Konflikt nur das Zeug hat zu
einem Flächenbrand zu werden das ist
möglicher das ist wir das hat weltkrieg
Potential leider muss man so sagen also
mehr noch würde ich sagen als der
Angriffskrieg Russlands auf die Ukraine
denn hier spielen so viele Player mit
ich meine auf der israelischen Seite die
USA stehen dort Europa zumindest auf der
politischen Ebene hoffentlich stehen
auch auf der Seite Israels in der
islamischen der sogenannten islamischen
Welt das ist ja faszinierend zu
beobachten wo Sunniten und Schiiten
eigentlich aufs Blut verfeindet sind ist
dieser Graben plötzlich innerhalb von
Sekunden zu wenn es gemeinsam ging
Israel geht ich meine dass die Hisbollah
die Hamas eine schitische Miliz eine
eine eine sunnitische unterstützt dass
jetzt plötzlich auch Saudi-Arabien und
Iran eigentlich in in den vergangenen in
der Vergangenheit immer nur durch
Konflikt geprägt jetzt plötzlich mehr
oder weniger auf derselben Seite stehen
Russland Russland unterstützt ich meine
das ist auch absurd ein ein Land das mit
Religion nichts am Hut hat mit Islam
schon gar nicht die als Ungläubige
bezeichnet wurden als sie damals in
Afghanistan waren sind jetzt plötzlich
eher auf der Seite der Palästinenser
also da spielen so viele Kräfte mit dass
dort ein Stellvertreterkrieg entstehen
kann der wirklich verheerend sein wird
das heißt aber Frau glass wie werden die
USA z.B reagieren je nach Situation kann
man absehen wenn das und das passiert
werden die USA z.B so und so reagieren
ich meine wir haben jetzt diese zwei
Flugzeugträger die entsandt wurden aber
was sie haben gerade genickt bei dem
Weltkriegsszenario ja leider habe ich
genickt ich nicke ungern aber ich sehe
das auch so ja ähm die USA sind
traditionell an der Seite Israels und
daran wird sich meiner Meinung nach auch
nichts ändern aber die anderen
Verbündeten die man sich jetzt so
langsam aufgebaut hat andere arabische
Länder die werden meiner Meinung nach
sofort weg sein weil das können die sich
gar nicht erlauben wenn wir jetzt diese
hohe Zahl auch ziviler Toten
Palästinenser sehen dass da ein
arabisches Land noch sagt ach ich habe
ja vor einem Jahr ein Abkommen mit
Israel geschlossen jetzt stehe ich an
der Seite Israels das glaube ich ist
vorbei und das ist ähm extrem gefährlich
was wir gerade sehen und wir sehen ja
nicht nur dass es in der Region dort ä
droht zu einem ganz ganz großen
Flächenbrand zu werden diese der
Konflikt ist ja längst in unseren
Ländern angekommen Frankreich hier bei
uns die Demonstrationen in den USA
überall und das macht mir auch ganz ganz
ganz große Sorge das heißt aber die USA
müssten ja in Zweifelsfall irgendwann
reagieren und nicht nur einfach ja die
Gefahr besteht bish haben sie gesagt sie
werden sich nicht direkt einmischen
aber tatsächlich sie haben es gesagt im
Flugzeugträger in der Region zand
weitere Schiffe auch sehr viele
Flugzeuge das heißt da wird auch eine
drokulisse aufgebaut und hoffentlich
bleibt dabei dass es nur eine drogolis
ist und das nicht tatsächlich eine
Situation entsteht in der die USA dann
auch tatsächlich Eingreifen das heißt
wer kann denn dann jetzt vermitteln in
dieser Situation wer
es gibt versuche man Frau berbuck war ja
jetzt
Verg Region es gibt sich einige die sich
anbieten der von Qatar war ja jetzt auch
Unterstützer der Hamas dieser Woche
genau und der hat die haben Milliarden
in den gaserstreifen gebumst unter dem
Stichwort
Wiederaufbau also eigentlich eine Rolle
die man auch hinterfragen sollte nur es
gibt e wenige direkte gesprächskanale
Kanäle das ist einer davon das andere
ist die Türkei die auch Hamas nie als
Terrororganisation eingestuft hat da hat
Erdogan sich auch angeboten
und will da vermitteln Russland
Präsident Putin hat sofort den
palästinensischen Präsidenten Mahmut
Abbas eingeladen der ja der offizielle
Vertreter der palästinens ist aber
wahrscheinlich von dieser Sache nicht
einmal was gewusst hat im Ansatz weil er
weil die zwei Gruppen tatsächlich sehr
verfeindet sind also Hamas und veratach
und die Autonomiebehörde also eine sehr
sehr schwierige Gemengelage und die her
versucht zu profitieren Frau berbock ist
unterwegs Außenministerin seit Freitag
sie war in Israel in Ägypten hat auch
mit dem türkischen Außenminister
gesprochen versucht da wie gesagt alle
Kanäle offen zu halten
kann Deutschland eine Vermittlerrolle
einnehmen im Nahen Osten oder vielleicht
nur auf EU-Ebene oder informell über den
BND gab's ja auch schon in der
Vergangenheit immer wieder ja versuche
da auch
ja einzugreifen zu vermitteln zu
unterstützen ich glaube ehrlich gesagt
Deutschlands Möglichkeiten da zu
vermitteln sind nicht mehr so stark wie
sie mal waren das was es jetzt
eigentlich bräuchte wäre Vermittlung
nach Teran mm das ist der der Punkt an
dem wirklich Vermittlung notwendig ist
Katar kann das machen die Saudis es
können glaube ich auch wichtige Signale
senden weil dem Iran diese
wiederernnäherung an Saudi-Arabien
wichtig ist Deutschland hatte mal gute
Kontakte in den Iran aber wenn man
sowohl mit deutschen Diplomaten als auch
mit iranischen Diplomaten spricht dann
sagen die das hat sich geändert weil aus
iranischer Sicht Deutschlands Haltung im
Atomstreit zu hart war ich glaube aber
wenn ich ein bisschen deeskalieren darf
ja das kann ein Weltkrieg werden aber
ich glaube soweit sind wir noch nicht
weil der Iran möchte meiner Meinung nach
die ganz große Konfrontation noch nicht
das si noch nicht heißt wann denn wenn
er sich in der noch stärkeren Position
sieht aber interessant ist der iranische
Außenminister der jetzt in die Region
gereist ist hat eindeutig gesagt ob die
hisbolla den großen Schlag führt das
liegt in der Hand der hisbolla und das
heißt die hisbolla darf auch sagen wir
führen diesen Schlag nicht und das
gefährliche in dieser Situation ist
nicht dass jemand gerade diesen
Weltkrieg plant das gefährliche in der
aktuellen Situation ist dass er einfach
aus Versehen passiert und das liegt vor
allem an den Raketen der hisbolla hat
140.000 Raketen das ist so viel dass ist
Israels Raketenabwehr wirklich ein
ernsthaftes Problem
m bereiten kann nur Raketen kann man nur
einmal verschießen das heißt
noch mal kann sie diese Waffe nicht
einsetzen Raketen kann können nicht
weglaufen das heißt die hisbolla weiß
wenn Israel da einmal drauf haut dann
ist die Arbeit von Jahren dahin und wir
haben jetzt eine Situation wo beide
Seiten sowohl die Israelis als auch die
hisbolla das Gefühl haben können K wir
müssen jetzt zuschlagen sonst ist alles
zu spät und das auf diese artenen Krieg
entsteht eine Sache ist sicher der
gefährlichste Punkt wird wenn die
Bodenoffensive begonnen hat und wenn die
Hamas kurz vor dem Ende steht das
könnten beides Gründe für die hisbolla
sein einzugreifen und was wir auch mit
Sicherheit sagen können ist wenn die
hisbolla den ganz großen Schlag wagt
dann tut sie das mit Zustimmung Terrans
und dann wissen wir dass Teran zu einer
regionalen Konfrontation zu dem ganz
großen Krieg bereit ist und dann ist
Welt kriegsgeswen ich wollte nur kurz
sagen weil sie gesagt haben der
iranische Außenminister habe gesagt es
liege im Messen der Hisbollah ich fand
aber trotzdem genau das stimmt nicht
erstens und ich fand auch interessant
dass er gesagt hat die hisbolla hat aber
verschiedene Eskalationsstufen a er hat
quasi als Sprecher der hispol fungiert
das fand ich auch spannend und das fand
ich auch wiederum entlafend weil er hat
klar gemacht in Wahrheit werden die
Entscheidungen in tierang getroffen da
wird's gesteuert ich würde gerne
aufnehmen was Frau glass eben noch mal
gesagt hat d dieser Konflikt dieser
Krieg ja auch in andere Länder getragen
wird wir haben es gesehen wir haben auch
so ein paar Bilder dabei es gab
Demonstrationen jetzt schon in vielen
Ländern auch pro Palästina
Demonstrationen wir haben ich glaube die
Bilder ich sehe sie gerade nicht da sind
sie aus London New York und auch
Düsseldorf gestern zu
sehen das ist natürlich etwas was auch
viele Menschen hier bei uns in
Deutschland interessiert wo wird dieser
Konflikt hingetragen was bedeutet er
auch hier bei uns im Land und deswegen
würde
das gerne noch mit reinnehmen hier in
unsere Sendung wir haben es gerade schon
verstanden also eine wichtige
Vermittlerfunktion hat Deutschland
vermutlich im Konflikt selbst im Nahen
Osten nicht was kann man hier in
Deutschland tun wir haben es gehört
Bundeskanzler Scholz hat verschiedene
Sachen angekündigt ein Betätigungsverbot
für die Hamas Vereinsverbot für samidun
wie viel Symbolpolitik ist das das ist
Symbolpolitik wenn auch eine wichtige
ich finde es wichtig dass das passiert
ist ich finde ist ein ganz klares
Zeichen aber den Antisemitismus bekommt
man ja nicht mit Verboten aus dem Köpfen
ich kann ihn ja nicht verbieten und ich
denke da
sind langfristige Konzepte gefragt
Stichwort Integration der muslimischen
Community etc aber sicherlich kein
verbotm sie haben es Herr wmer sie haben
erlebt wie in Berlin z.B versucht wird
damit umzugehen auch in Schulen wir
haben es gerade gesagt den
Antisemitismus kriegt man davon ja nicht
einfach weg wo wo kann man das dann
überhaupt an packen mit Verboten
offensichtlich nicht ich bin mir nicht
so sicher ob Verbote nicht auch der
richtige Weg sind ich glaube schon ich
glaube noch wichtiger wenn wir es jetzt
quasi einfach auf der Ebene der inneren
Sicherheit betrachten ist dass unsere
Sicherheitsbehörden endlich so
ausgestattet werden dass sie dem
Gefährdungspotenzial was da dahinter
steht ähm wirklich begegnen können
zweitens ist wichtig dass bestimmte
Institutionen in Deutschland auch nicht
mehr aus politischen Gründen geduldet
werden z.B die ihre iranische das das
islamische Zentrum Hamburg das Iran was
wirklich ein Zentrum auch der iranischen
Politik auch der Sicherheitsdienst ist
das wird geduldet weil man denkt dass
man damit gute Kontakte zum Iran
erhalten
kann ich glaube aber auch dass wir nicht
überreagieren dürfen wenn jetzt es in an
Berliner Schulen ermöglicht wird die
Aussage free Palestine zu verbieten dann
glaube ich dass wir einen Schritt
weitgen das ist ist ein Plan den es gibt
in Berlin ja das ist jetzt erlassen
worden es ist kein zwingendes Verbot
sondern das ermöglicht Schulen
Sticker zu verbieten T-Shirts zu
verbieten wo das drauf steht natürlich
kann dieser Slogan auch von der Hamas
und ihren Anhänger missbraucht werden
aber ich glaube die Aussage als solche
dass jemand sich Freiheit wünscht oder
einem Land Freiheit wünscht das ist per
se noch keine extremistische Aussage und
ich glaube wir sollten auch aus dem 11
September und der dessen Nachwirkung
lernen dass wir die Freiheit nicht
verteidigen können indem wir sie
beschneiden und wir müssen diesen Kampf
der jetzt auch in unseren Gesellschaften
stattfinden wird den müssen wir auch
zusammen mit Muslimen gewinnen und da
darf Freiheit wünschen als solches noch
keine Straftat das stimmt schon dass man
das darf natürlich darf man sich
Freiheit wünschen
aber also sehr persönlich gesprochen
wenn ein schwarzer Mensch umgebracht
wird und es entsteht der Slogan black
lives matter und dann kommt jemand und
sagt aber all lives matter dann stimmt
das auch aber das ist der falsche
Zeitpunkt denn dieses all lives matter
ist ein Versuch der Relativierung des
Problems das wir haben und genauso ist
es jetzt ein Fehler jetzt davon zu reden
aber alle Seiten sind schuld und wir
dürfen das nicht tun ich glaube man muss
schon sehr klar benennen was das Problem
ist und und das ist das was mich
wirklich traurig macht und schockiert
wenn ich sehe dass in Berlin Häuser in
denen Juden Leben mit dem Davidstern
markiert werden konte man gestern z.B in
sozialen Netzwerken wenn ich sehe und
höre dass die Integrationsbeauftragte
des Berliner Bezirks Neuköln sagt sie
würde nicht empfehlen heute den Juden
erkennbar ihre Religion nach draußen zu
tragen weil es gefährlich ist weil große
Teile der arabischsprachigen Community
dort mit einer Terrororganisation
sympathisieren dann ist das beschämend
dass in der deutschen Bundeshauptstadt
die mal Hauptstadt auch jenes Landes war
das für den Nationalsozialismus
verantwortlich war Juden nicht mehr ihr
Leben frei leben können und das ist no
Goo areas gibt für Juden das ist
beschämend und furchtbar und da muss man
auch ehrlicherweise sagen nicht weil man
das Feld den Rechtsextremisten
überlassen will sondern weil man aus
Herzen überzeugt ist dass so etwas nicht
sein darf müssen wir über
Integrationspolitik sprechen was da
alles schiefläuft könnte noch mal eine
extra pressclubsendung sowieso wieder
sein dieses Thema ähm aber wir sehen
dass diese die Konflikte und auch die
Auswirkungen bei uns spürbar sein werden
in Deutschland wir haben gerade geschaut
auf den die Situation im Gasastreifen
die
Zivilbevölkerung wenn wir das mal alles
so im Kopf haben und wissen was
möglicherweise passiert würde mich so
zum zum Schluss dieser Runde
interessieren wie Sie das bewerten wie
lange wird die Unterstützung anhalten
die es aktuell für Israel gibt wir
werden die Bilder bekommen aus dem
Gazastreifen die schlimmer sein werden
haben wir gerade schon erlebt wie wie
lange wird die Unterstützung halten auch
aus solidarischen Ländern wie aus
Deutschland
ich glaube dass es eine klare
Solidarität gibt mit Israel die aber
mehr und mehr auch verbunden mit einem
aber sein wird dass man tatsächlich
hinweist und auch hinweisen muss es gibt
eine Zivilbevölkerung gaserstreffen die
muss versorgt werden und es gilt hier
tatsächlich die nächsten humanitäre die
nächste humanitäre Katastrophe auch zu
verhindern und ich finde man
darf nicht so weit gehen dass man nicht
mehr darauf verweisen darf aufgrund
dieser Sache was da passiert ist zu
sagen hey es gibt eigentlich eine eine
zwei staatenlösung die auch die
europäischen Staaten immer wieder den
Palästinensern versprochen haben also
dass man jetzt seit geht und sagt auch
das darf nicht mehr thematisiert werden
weil das jetzt geschehen ist das finde
geht tatsächlich zu weit und
das Schlimme an dieser Sache jetzt ist
dass der kollaterals schauen massiv ist
also wie Susanne glass gesagt hat die
arabischen Staaten die bis Abkommen mit
Israel seit 2020 geschlossen haben
Schritte in Richtung Normalisierung
Anerkennung wie eben die feinig
Arabischen Emirate wie bachrein das wird
alles zurückgedreht werden das ist das
eine und auch die Schwierigkeit für
Israelis die sie seit vielen Jahren
einsetzen für eine zweist staatenlösung
das weiterhin zu artikulieren oder auch
palästinensische Gruppen in Deutschland
oder Deutsche die sich für einen
palästinensischen Staat für eine
Friedenslösung zum Teil seit
Jahrzehnten einsetzen für all die wird's
schwieriger werden fr hab diese
Gespaltenheit haben sie gerade ja selber
aus sich heraus beschrieben und das wird
sich ja genauso weiterentwickeln aber
ich bekomme diese Gespaltenheit ich ich
kann damit um gehen weil ich versuche
sie dahingehen zu balancieren dass ich
mir sage eine Errungenschaft unserer
Demokratien unserer Zivilgesellschaften
ist die Menschlichkeit und wir dürfen
uns diese Menschlichkeit nicht von
Terroranschlägen zerstören lassen ich
versuche immer noch menschlich zu
bleiben und zu sagen hier gibt's
Menschen da gibt's Menschen und darauf
hinzuwirken dass der Hass der jetzt so
überhand nimmt und auf der anderen Seite
die Angst in unseren Gesellschaften dass
das wieder vielleicht etwas weniger wird
und mit einem
vernünftigeren Blick äh die Situation
betrachtet wird so schwierig es
erscheint das ist meiner Meinung nach im
Moment die einzige Lösung und sie haben
gefragt nach Solidarität ich glaube
schon dass der Westen dass die USA an
der Solidarität mit Israel festhalten
werden da bin ich mir relativ sicher das
wünsche ich mir auch ähm aber die
Gesellschaft muss mitgenommen werden das
ist glaube ich auch Deut Punkt weil also
die Bundesregierung wird auf jeden Fall
dabei sein ich meine wenn man sich die
Rede anhört von von Vizekanzler habbeck
wunderbar Solidarität ob die
Gesellschaft überall so mitmacht weiß
ich nicht dann müssen wir das so als
Fragestellung am Ende dieser Sendung
stehen lassen haben aber gemerkt
menschlichkeit ist immerhin etwas was
uns auch bleibt bei aller Angst die hier
auch mit im Raum spürbar ist das war der
pressclub ich danke Ihnen für die
Diskussion für ihre Einschätzung auch
für ihre persönlichen Geschichten danke
Ihnen dass Sie dabei waren im ersten
geht's weiter mit dem europamagazin da
ist auch Israel aktuelles Thema und bei
uns geht's weiter WDR5 und Phönix mit
presseub
[Musik]
nachgefragt so und da sind wir zurück
mit dem pressclub nachgefragt unser
Thema heute ist Israel im Krieg droht
ein Flächenbrand im Nahen Osten bin
gespannt mit welchen Fragen und
Meinungen Sie sich bei uns melden ich
nehme direkt mal Anne gret punanch dazu
hallo Frau Punch aus Hagen
ja guten Tag an sie alle also ich bin
innerlich sehr aufgewühlt also wirklich
der aufgewühlt wenn ich das höre weil
ich mich ewige Zeiten mit Geschichte
beschäftige und immer wieder ist Israel
dieses dieser Brennpunkt also jetzt
meine Frage ganz kurz um was geht es dem
der hisbolla und den Palästinensern
eigentlich wirklich nur um das reine
Land oder um das jüdische Volk gänzlich
auszurutten man kann es bald nicht mehr
ertragen irgendwie dann siedeln wir das
jüdische Volk umbringen es in Sicherheit
oder bring es wieder unter uns dass sie
da in Sicherheit sind um was geht es den
Leuten da ja danke schön Frau für Ihre
Fragestellung wer mag Antworten Herr
bümer dann wenn wir diese beiden
Organisationen nehmen Hamas und
Hezbollah denen geht es mit Sicherheit
und die vollkommene Zerstörung des
Staates Israel es sind auch
Organisationen die immer mehr
antisemitisch sich äußern das heißt der
jüdische das jüdische Volk insgesamt ist
der Feind das gilt nicht für alle
Palästinenser für diese beiden
Organisationen gilt es ganz bestimmt
vielleicht auch noch als Ergänzung
Präsident Abbas hat ja damals die zwei
starenlösungen mit einem israelischen
general 1977 ausgearbeitet gegen den
Widerstand von Jassi Arafat damals der
da eigentlich der Anführer war und der
ist für eine zweite staatenlösung aber
die hermass hat seit 1988 eine charatte
und da steht ganz klar drin sie wollen
dass die Flagge alas über ganz Palästina
WT also zwischen Mittelmeer und Jordan
die erheben Anspruch auf das ganze Land
so wie auch muss man sagen jetzige
Regierungsmitglied in Israel die
wiederum großisrael auf dieser Fläche
machen wollen verwirklichen wollen ich
hole Herr Müller in unsere Runde Harald
Müller aus Krefeld hallo guten Tag ja
schönen guten Tag in die Runde mir
geht's in meiner Frage um die
Glaubwürdigkeit oder das ernstnehmen
unserer Politiker durch die Bank durch
die Bank und zwar um die beiden Begriffe
staatsrison und an der Seite Israels
wenn es so wäre dass Israel Staatsraison
ist ist kommt die Frage auf wenn die
israelische Armee nicht mehr genug
Truppen besitzt nicht mehr genug
Soldaten besitzt und Truppen anfordert
müsste Deutschland aufgrund der beiden
Begriffe Truppen schicken ist unsere
Armee überhaupt dafür ausgerüstet in
einen Häuserkampf oder in einen
Untergrundkampf zu gehen und meinen
unsere Politiker das wirklich ernst oder
sind das nur Lippenbekenntnisse danke
schön Herr Müller für Ihre Frage Herr
kim hat schon
gesagt also ich meine die Bundeswehr gut
genug zu kennen zu behaupten dass sie
sicherlich überfordert wäre mit so einer
Geschichte die zweite Frage ist
natürlich ob die Bundeswehr überhaupt
angefordert werden würde ich glaube die
israelische Armee ist schon sehr sehr
stark sehr sehr gut ausgebildet sehr gut
trainiert zu den Politikern und
Politikerinnen na ja jetzt ist die Zeit
zu beweisen ob das nur ein
Lippenbekenntnis ist und ich sehe
schon dass es
jetzt eine Situation ist wo man wirklich
auch sich überlegen muss wie geht man um
auch mit den anti-israelischen
Äußerungen die hier in Deutschland immer
wieder aus der Gesellschaft herauskommen
aus bestimmten Gruppen aus
unterschiedlichen Gruppen also insofern
jetzt jetzt muss man natürlich klar
Position bekennen die meisten Politiker
zumindest aus der Bundesregierung tun
das ich habe ja in einem Tweet hier zur
Sendung Ankündigung geschrieben dass ich
über das dröhnende Schweigen der
politischen Linken etwas erstaunt bin
dass sie zurecht immer Rechtsextremismus
kritisiert zurecht aber hier doch
schweigt wurde dafür wiederum kritisiert
das würde nicht stimmen na ja also das
ist ein nicht nur ein Problem der
Bundesregierung sondern ich sehe auch
das Problem weltweit bei der politischen
Linkung wenn ich sehe Frau Alexandria
ocasio Cortes eine amerikanische
Politikerin und Ikone der Linken dort
die vier Tage lang nichts gesagt hat zu
dem Thema nach dem Anschlag um dann zu
sagen man müsse auf beiden Seiten sehen
dass es da Probleme gibt finde ich das
schwierig und deswegen ist dieses
Bekenntnis wir stehen zu Israel auch aus
deutscher Seite und es ist eine
stsraison das muss tatsächlich dann auch
erfüllt werden und gefüllt werden mit
handeln also auch nötig auch einfach
etwas zu sagen und dann folgen die
Handlungen aus Ortenberg ist Mark Hebbel
in unserer Runde hallo Herr
Hebbel ja hallo in die Runde Ihre Frage
bitte um mich kurz zu fassen im
Gegensatz zu vielen anderen die Frage
ist wann kapiert das palätinensische
Volk dass Sie unter einer Diktatur
leiden und sich nicht gegen die diese
diese Terroristen wären die flüchten
jetzt schlimm genug oder müssen flüchten
aber warum geht das Volk nicht gegen
diese dususselige terrorregierung vor
das die Frage danke schön Herr Hebbel es
gibt Demonstrationen immer wieder im
gaserastreifen westjordnland also auf
der einen Seite gegen die vertach und
die Autonomiebehörde die korrupt ist da
geht auch abas mit harter Hand vor wirft
auch Menschen ins Gefängnis und die Herr
M Susanne Klass hat vor auch geschildert
dass immer mehr Menschen sich von ihr
abgewandt haben in den vergangenen
Jahren selbst dort gab es
Demonstrationen und da wird mit harter
Hand einfach regiert also die Menschen
versuchen schon ihre Möglichkeiten zu
nutzen andererseits und das läge
tatsächlich in palästinensischer Hand
Wahlen anzusetzen abas müsste das
eigentlich seit 2009 tun und macht es
nicht weil er e fürchtet dass die herass
erneut die stärkste Partei ist also das
ist auch etwas was eigentlich in Händen
der palästinensischen Führung lege
wieder Wahlen anzusetzen auch das ist in
den vergangenen Jahren nicht passiert
auch in unserer Runde ist heute morgen
Konstanza lungo aus Essen hallo herzlich
willkommen guten
Tag meine Frage ist was oder wer hindert
dass jetzt eine
zweatenlösung erfolgt wird früher es war
klar aber was hindert das jetzt alles
klar nehmen wir mit in die Runde danke
Ihnen für die Frage bmer ja da gibt es
mindestens zwei haupterklärungen dafür
einmal die Palästinenser sind im Moment
so gespalten zwischen Hamas und fatach
dass sie gar nicht in der Lage wären
gemeinsam eine zwei staatenlösung zu
realisieren und ein Teil dieser
palästinensischen Politik nämlich die
Hamas will keine Zweistaatenlösung also
wir reden da müssen wir kurz sagen
Gazastreifen Westjordanland damit wir
wissen wo wir befinden genau richtig die
Hamas im Gazastreifen auch wenn sich es
zwischendurch schon mal so getan hat als
sei sie bereits einer zwei staatenlösung
äh ist sie
erkennbar kein Partner für so eine
Lösung es ist aber auch so dass
natürlich der israelische
siedlungsbauern den
Palästinensergebieten das Territorium
auf dem dieser
Palästinenserstaat entstehen müsste
stark zerschnitten hat also ist auch
schon die Frage wo soll das passieren es
gibt aber durchaus auch Leute die sagen
vielleicht gibt es auch eine
einstaatenlösung in der beide diese
Völker demokratische Rechte haben können
wenn ich da noch was dazu sagen darf sie
haben vollkommen recht mit allem was Sie
sagen aber auch die israelische
Regierung unter Netanyahu jetzt hatte ja
überhaupt kein Interesse mehr in einer
Zweistaatenlösung das Thema war ja schon
seit Jahren vom Tisch da hat niemand
mehr darüber gesprochen ich glaube dass
das auch mit ein Grund ist für die ganz
große Frustration der Palästinenser
jetzt glaube ich aber tatsächlich dass
wenn die weiter existiert dass für
Israel keine Option ist eine
Zweistaatenlösung anzudenken mit einem
palästinensischen Staat in dem die has
weiter mit an der Macht beteiligt ist
wir nehmen aus Eisenach in Thüringen
Georg Günther mit dazu hallo Herr
Günther einen schönen guten Tag auch in
die Runde
und ich gehe davon aus dass jede Wirkung
eine Ursache hat und ich sehe mit in dem
Konflikt die Ursache dass eben
Völkerrecht gebrochen worden ist in den
besetzten Gebiet bien werden nach wie
vor Häuser gebaut es wird kritisiert
aber es passiert nicht weiter es wurde
Jerusalem annektiert der Ostteil von
Jerusalem war da auch zur Hauptstadt von
Israel erklärt das westjürderanland soll
auch annektiert werden wo bleibt das
volkerrecht bei den Ukrain bzw bei
Russland wden sofort Sanktionen verhängt
warum macht man das nicht gegen Israel
die auch Völkerrecht ständig sprechen
das ist meine Frage danke dan schön Herr
Günther nehmen wir mit in die Runde der
siedlungsbaut sich tatsächlich
intensiviert in den
vergangenen Monaten noch mal dadurch
dass auch
Rechtsextreme Vertreter in der Regierung
sind es sind mehr als 500.000 Menschen
die mittlerweile im im Bereich von
Siedler die im Bereich Westjordanland
erleben und jetzt e tatsächlich noch mal
aktiver sind auch durch diese Regierung
durchaus
befördert das macht schwieriger Herr
Bömer hat's vorhin auch schon skizziert
aber nichtsdestotrotz gibt's nur immer
Menschen die glauben es wäre machbar
wenn man etwa entlang der Grenze
zwischen Westjordanland und Israel e
einen Streifen wo die meisten Siedlungen
sich konzentrieren
abtrennen würde diesen Teil Israel
zuschlagen würde dann könnten rund
80% der sied sozusagen werden auf der
israelischen Seite dann müsste man aber
den Palästinensern tatsächlich auch
anders W Land geben es setzt aber voraus
einen politischen Willen und den gibt es
auf Seiten der jetzigen israelischen
Regierung tatsächlich nicht wenn ich
noch eine Sache hinzufügen darf zu dem
Vergleich Ukraine israelpästinenser
Konflikt dieser Vergleich funktioniert
meiner Meinung nach so nicht m der
Israeli der israelischpalästinensische
Konflikt hat angefangen mit Territorium
das von Juden in Palästina legal
erworben wurde besiedelt wurde dann gab
es Pläne für eine Teilung die die Araber
immer abgelehnt haben die Palästinenser
immer abgelehnt haben und dann gab es
eine Konfliktdynamik die uns hier hin
geführt hat wo wir sind das ist ein
vollkommen anderer Fall als Ukraine und
Russland zwei etablierte Staaten mit
klaren Grenzen und der eine marschiert
in den anderen ein okay aus Oldenburg
ist roswiita Greif ja ja hallo guten Tag
fr meine Frage ist oder sagen wir soum
es wundert mich eigentlich dass weder
von der Presse noch von der Politik Frau
strck Zimmermann hat das mal ganz
vorsichtig angedeutet auf die Idee
gekommen ist dass die Russen die Iraner
angespitzt haben der Hamas sozusagen zu
sagen mach das jetzt damit ich dieich
damit die Weltbevölkerung die Welt auf
Israel guckt sich um Israel kümmert und
ich kann hier in der Ukraine Ruh machen
denn die unterstüt ung wird dann nach
Israel gehen und nicht mehr an die
Ukraine also das heißt welche Rolle
spielt Russland für sie gut nehmen wir
auf in die Runde Herr Kassim also ich
kann dazu nur sagen nach allem was ich
lese aber ich bin da jetzt nicht
spezifisch in diesem Thema eingearbeitet
ist das klingt das plausibel aber
letztlich ist das nicht belegbar also
ich weiß es nicht ob Russland das
tatsächlich getan hat ich höre und lese
das oft aber immer als Spekulation und
als Frage formuliert und nie dass es
irgendwo handfeste Beweise dass es
Dokumente gibt Belege oder das Akteure
sagen so sei es gewesen deswegen ähm ist
das glaube ich der Grund dass wir
darüber jetzt nicht so intensiviert
reden weil das im Bereich der
Spekulation bleibt dem schließe ich mich
an auf der anderen Seite profitiert
natürlich Russland jetzt äh von von
dieser Situation wer schaut im Moment
auf den ukrainekrieg und
ich weiß gar nicht ob der Iran überhaupt
angespitzt werden muss von Russland
möglicherweise ähm fügt er äh das selbst
zusammen wie gerade die Situation ist
und denkt jetzt wäre die richtige Zeit
gewesen für diesen wahnsinnsschlag gegen
Israel und noch war noch ein Szenario
zuzufügen
es gibt zumindest auch in deutschen
politischen kreisende Befürchtung dass
auch China
jetzt die Zeit nutzen könnte
Stichwort wann wenn man auch ohne Belege
lässt sich das wahrscheinlich noch sehr
weit ausbreiten Herrn König aus München
würde ich gerne auch noch mit reinnehmen
hallo Herr König ja schönen guten Tag
ich wollte an die Runde die Frage
stellen inwiew weit denn nicht generell
mal die Frage oder die Prüfung gemacht
werden muss inwiew weit die deutsche
Politik jetzt nicht nur der Ampel
sondern der letzten 20 Jahre im Grunde
versagt hat denn wir stehen jetzt V
einem scherbenhaufenzug worau haben
innenpitisch inen wir haben
innenpolitisch keine Integration kein
Verband
der Muslime oder Palästinenser geht auf
die Straße um gegen diese Taten zu
protestieren sondern sie verteilen
Kuchen
wir haben kein Anker irgendwo wo die
Frau bärbock hinfahren könnte und ein
Land aktivieren das in in der ja
nahöstlichen islamischen Welt sich auf
unsere Seite stellen würde also nicht
auf die deutsche aber auf die die des
Westens oder die Israels sondern wir
haben im Grunde einen Flächenbrand und
keine Handhabe wir sind noch nicht mal
militärisch in der
Lage Sie bitte Ihre Frage noch sch die
Frage ist die Frage ist ist unsere
Außenpolitik hinsichtlich des Nahen
Ostens oder aber auch der islamischen
Länder nicht krachend gescheitert alles
klar Herr König vielen Dank noch eine
schnelle Antwort dazu Herr bümer sie ist
krachend gescheitert Herr König da haben
sie recht weil es sie eigentlich gar
nicht gab wir haben in Deutschland
eigentlich in den letzten Jahrzehnten
immer gesagt wir stehen hundertprozentig
zu Israel und das ist auch völlig
richichttig und alles weitere haben wir
den USA überlassen aber die USA haben
klar gemacht sie werden sich im Nahen
Osten weniger engagieren und wir
Deutschen und Europäer haben uns kein
Konzept überlegt wie wir das Auffangen
und wir müssen es auffangen das heißt
was wäre jetzt der richtige Schritt wenn
Sie das so formulieren also wie sollte
man sich jetzt anders aufstellen ganz
kurz noch also erstens ist es richtig
Israel weiter 100%z sich zu unterstützen
es ist auch richtig zu den arabischen
Ländern die für Zusammenarbeit mit dem
West offen sind mit denen die Bündnisse
zu stärken und das hat die
Bundesregierung auch schon getan sowohl
in den Gesprächen mit Saudi-Arabien als
auch mit Katar ich danke Ihnen für die
Antworten ich danke Ihnen dass Sie Ihre
Fragen und ihre Meinung mit reingebracht
haben in den Presseclub das war's von
uns an diesem Sonntag mit ja einem
schwierigen Gefühl am Ende aber danke
für Ihre Einschätzung und Ihnen noch
einen schönen Sonntag bis
[Musik]
bald